[Music]
hey what's up as filmmakers on YouTube
we come up with lots of weird ideas we
write them down on paper and hope that
one day they come to life today is one
of those days because as you can see
behind me we have a lot of Tanks yes
that's right we are at drive a tank in
Kasota
Minnesota that's right our home state
and we are super excited this is the
United States's first recreational tank
driving facility we have a special
opportunity the guys over at world of
tanks have been like hey we love your
videos we'd love to make another video
involving tanks you down we're down let
me introduce to you the story of me mom
first thing on the list today we have to
location scout we've written script
however we haven't seen what the mobile
home the key location in this we don't
know what it looks like on the inside
hopefully the kind of lines up if it
doesn't well we're gonna have to
restructure the script today because
we're shooting tomorrow you get my back
we're just like a mystery chemicals
you just spray it on the back of hand
then you go like this freakin love how
big tanks are people easily forget how
how small you are cleared
it's a tactical smoke maneuver there's
at least three climate changes coming
out of that story this house is how I've
heard is that this actually belonged to
a convicted felon convicted two weeks
ago and now this was just left because
he's gonna be in jail for a long time in
the toilet like other anyway you're not
even there on the floor it has to feel
like Nima's actual house that you need
to live there we have to go thrift store
shop in Goodwill's
hit up some furniture get everything
just to make it feel like a bit of a
home set deck and props and just some of
the stuff particularly bring this whole
thing together it's so much fun oh yeah
this in one transaction was at least
2530 one happy thank you so much are you
sure that we will be around the back to
get the furniture
oh my god this is the Extreme Home
Makeover here we have this place there
is just nightmares all over this mobile
home so we're here to make it our dream
home they're basically taking everything
apart and putting it back together and
again like Legos this for example this
is this is what would happen if you
hired me to be a contractor at your
house we're making it look like the
house is it at least like reasonable
like will be believe lived in just
barely livable oh my god oh my god this
is so legit you guys so you have a couch
instead of making that the bedroom we
can double down and just make up in dope
living room yeah I have it
welcome to me most cribs this place was
a total hole before we got here and we
made this whole thing a me mas dream
start in the kitchen here Kitchen Rules
read these or you don't get the hang out
with us all right this is where we keep
our stove here you can see the printers
underneath lighting those far as we
start we literally like the woman what
Bernie so we have our drawers here our
cabinets that bolted shut
dirty forks in the sink to be washed all
right we have our food we have our
cookies
our cheese nips little nips up in there
best books ever you know what honestly
it is the only one I tried to read it's
the Star Wars science fair book I like
the pictures over here we have the best
collectibles you've ever seen poor
swimmers porcelain baby boys crystalline
eggs not candy yet porcelain thing I
don't know what's going on but you know
what you want to see a porcelain thing
that's gonna blow your mind
this is a hard fair man only hard bears
in Biman Taos moving over we have our
couch this world whereas this is where
we eat and dine in peace with our
strawberries and Butterworth's table
over here you know having some tea over
here this is where the magic happens
we got my dirty pants we got my dolls
secret treasure box we're gonna fill
that with my treasures we have our bed
where I sleep don't don't touch it or
sit on it it's actually full Spike's
this this girl the ear like it's it
started sliding down it's called sliding
your disease it slid all the way down
the chin
and last not least we have my closet
where does I keep my nice clothes the
room we've all been waiting for the
savvy savvy deaf room where we keep all
the banned chemicals and asbestos that's
where I'm Iman throws people who get
punished welcomes my freedom last thing
I bet you on Sam the cub G thing I knew
20 bucks for that and now you're gonna
owe me 20 more because Sam just bet me
he wouldn't say the word me ma tomorrow
I said it like it up to 200 times today
that meat and listen to my voice you
hear me you hear this voice it's not
gonna say those words again he's gonna
say it again before 10 a.m. he does they
mean or grandmother he really owes me
$80 tell you what you pay it in advance
you only owe me 30
however this as a man who is very
familiar with these fictional kind of
debts fantasy debts how do we put this
but-but-but okay what does this push-up
debt you have these thousands of
push-ups whoa hey Sam
that's a debt with another party it's
irrelevant to you don't concern yourself
with that
all right you got it so leverage maybe
if I lose all I'll be able to relate it
was a dad that I was already forgiven
the audience forgive me and if you pay
me now you only need to pay me 30 no
because I believe I have a shot at
winning this move over this bet not that
I'm gonna you're gonna sell me my
marijuana again a.m. tomorrow me ma
that's gotta burn that name out of my
mind it's not gonna happen man
for you let's forget it we even brought
with us our goal is think
and to say me mom before noon always
right there sitting today is that so you
basically are getting in here
and it's not hard to find start with mee
maws before 9 a.m.
Sam said me ma day 2 of the world of
tanks shoot from way back to the
location yesterday visit all the meaty
dialogue and kind of the specialized
shots that we needed before the big tank
did and when we get to actually run over
a entire house today should be a fun day
we all got to be hands on deck we're
gonna be running multiple cameras
multiple GoPros we're all gonna have to
run in there after each erected to cut
fish out cameras but it's gonna make for
some awesome footage
[Music]
cut should I have them turn around and
reset is that it you're good with that
this serves to show the power of the
vehicles that are coming towards the
home which I don't think I need to say
anything more than that
we have a good friend on set today a
good friend of mine which I will
introduce you to shortly
are you playing the game of life bro you
play the game of life you guys know each
other
yeah we do we don't wave at way back
we're gonna outfit you some let you hear
it up yes ma'am reveille what's up
everybody
new to me like watch it all and we put
it all together in one day thank you and
we're gonna be getting crazy shots we're
gonna be so frozen you're strolling the
tank busting into the rigs yeah you run
up and you say guys we have to get out
of here it's literally the apocalypse
come on okay you like saying it
literally be upon his face cells me
because he's like that's a wrap 15
minute cameo that is awesome
we're here today filming another war bit
and I got to say Christian and Quinn's
are completely out of line when it comes
to their costumes they're trying to play
goons today and I've been talking about
the goon life for many videos now and
I'm trying to show him the right way
clearly these guys don't even match they
don't look anything like me I think it's
honestly I think it's terrible uniforms
is fun
horrible what is this this light blue
how easy this is to see hey young man
stand down before your troops
Michael hawk are you here to kill me no
yes that's you straight I'm here to let
you know that actually the way that
these guys are operating is a very
viable strategic technique because of
the mismatched uniform the enemy cannot
tell if they're actually combatants if
their friends or foes if they're
civilians or not they can hide in plain
sight they can easily dawn or more
equipment and go in and make an attack
and then they can strip some stuff off
and blend right back into the populism
so actually what they're doing is a very
good stretch so stand corrected young
man and drive on one thing about today
is that we learned a lot about not only
how a pcs in tanks work but also how
mobile homes are constructed running em
over lengthwise is a bad idea because
the strongest structural points are on
either end so we decided to switch the
whole video to make it perpendicular
cutting the thing in half here's the
challenge we need to shoot more than one
shot in the house while it's being
crushed so we need to do it in stages
crush it a little bit film a little bit
crush it a little bit bit a little bit
we're doing it in four increments
because we strive to this video to
account for a total of four crushes now
we have no idea if the whole thing is
just gonna flatten out the moment the
tank bumps into it we have no idea if
the ceilings gonna cave in is one big
piece if it'll go down in chunks can we
crush one room without crushing all the
others at the same time we're set of
cameras all over the place also we don't
want the cameras and memory cards to get
destroyed so how are we gonna do this
well I think the first step for us is
finding some of these beams that are
kind of holding up a lot of the
structural weight placing the GoPros on
these areas or kind of underneath them
we're gonna film some composite shots
where walk off the camera Clinton
dives out of the way and then we ideally
I've no idea what's gonna happen ideally
are able to composite him basically into
a close call with the APC and we're
gonna do that throughout the day a bunch
of times if it doesn't go well
definitely gonna have a little bit of a
situation on our hands
you literally reel the entire piece
around these four shots I'm nervously
excited man
I feel like an extra 5 degrees hotter
I'm a blood is fun little faster cuz my
heart is beatin so running five cameras
in the house three cameras outside the
house this is gonna be a dope shot it's
gonna be basically a cinematic shot of
the hallway and the tanks gonna go look
wipe the hallway it's good and just as a
heads-up I'm gonna roll all the cameras
we are going to film this shot of him
exiting once Clint and myself are both
outside and give you the thumbs up yeah
that means they're ready to go that
means the cameras are still rolling okay
okay yeah all right here we go we are
rolling the cameras action
no one rolling yeah get my nose rolling
rolling
the driver
[Music]
it was mathematical way to get in there
and in there that was awesome dude that
couldn't work out better once he's out
of there and they give us the okay we
got to find all our GoPros PC you know
it was behind the couch so behind the
oh it's still it was still rolling yeah
they're all good so the sealy stayed up
which is really interesting it's like a
kraj door like when it came through the
other side wasn't expecting that at all
Sam's beautiful counters three more to
go
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a wrap
I've been and for the next 15 minutes
the longest series of high-fives was
recorded so after two of the most
grueling days of our lives
we're finally done with the truth and
it's going to be incredible guys check
out the video right now in the quarter
channel and if you make it to Minnesota
helpline a trip to Minnesota because if
you're here you got to check these guys
ups drive a tank in Kasota
once-in-a-lifetime experience is
incredible also huge things the guys
over at World of Tanks they they they
sponsored and supported this video and
there they've been great to work with so
you should definitely check out their
game links are in the description as
well thanks for watching as always see
you next time